here's another thing that that doesn't
make any sense but i have to show you
this
um
i don't have to but i'm going to and
we're trying to get through this
together as much as we can
the director of the nih francis collins
is stepping down
and he gave his last
address i guess to the public this is
supposed to be sort of a
press conference an address to the
public talking about
the pandemic talking about kovid
and his last
act what's this listen
[Music]
somewhere
past the pandemic
when
we're free
there's a
life i remember
full of activity
somewhere past the pandemic
masks will come off
no
more
need for a nose swab
every time
we cough
okay
just don't pause it because we might go
back to it
if you feel like if you guys feel like
you need to hear more of that
i don't know i was kind of getting into
it
let's just play a little bit more i want
to hear a little bit more of this song
play just play a little bit more
as we are gathered here today
covid's toll has hit and sent us really
[Applause]
but partners like the ones right here
will help to make the pathway clear
too far i find it true okay now we're
going to rewind it and watch the whole
thing again but this time i want you to
focus on the uh sign language
interpreter because that's a whole other
no i'm kidding we're not actually going
to play but that's a whole different
experience when you're watching the sign
language interpreter
who you can tell is painfully
embarrassed but she she has to just roll
with it
that's that's not uh
i i swear to you when i first saw this
on online i thought is this like a deep
fake thing this has got to be a joke
this cannot be real
i know we've seen this all over tik tok
people love singing about
kovid for some reason but there's no way
that francis collins the director of the
nhs but no this is real he actually did
that that is a thing that happened
and this this this shows you it shows
you a lot of things one is um
even before he broke out into song this
was the case that we see how
when people
get into a bureaucracy they become
bureaucrats
it has this effect of of lessening them
you know
and that's really a shame with francis
collins because he he in fact is a
brilliant scientist he was one of the
guys who sequenced the human genome i
mean he's one of the
he's a great brilliant scientist
but now this is what he has become
as a bureaucrat
my god
and we can we can laugh
in a cringy awkward way at that because
what else are you gonna do
but there is also something kind of
sinister about it
because what's it's it's this this
fanciful song about somewhere past the
pandemic everything will be good again
you could take the masks off
but just like we talk about somewhere
over the rainbow even in wizard of oz
and the place over the rainbow doesn't
really exist it's all a dream in the end
it's a bait and switch
which always bothered me even when i was
a kid i first saw that movie um so it's
it's not real is the point the place
over the rainbow is everything is great
it's but it's it's your it's in your
imagination it's in your dreams it's not
a real place
and that's
basically what we're being told there
and this thing goes from awkward to
creepy when you think of it that way
that what we're being told by the nih is
that the place past the pandemic it's
like the place over the rainbow in that
it doesn't exist because we're never
going to be past this this is how it's
going to be forever you're never taking
the mask off
if you live in a place where you still
have to wear it
you're never taking it off if you're in
california where i just was for a few
days suffering through uh you're never
taking the mask off
so that's the real message pass the
pandemic is a is a fantasy
but but but keep dreaming about it keep
thinking about it
and keep cooperating and obeying
and maybe one day
this this far-off fantasy will come to
fruition
that's the real message of the song hey
listen hit the subscribe button do it
right now
i demand it and i thank you for your
compliance it is somewhat appreciated